welcome back to cbs this morning
emotions are still running high in
rochester new york where daniel prue
died after a confrontation with police
back in march
angry but peaceful protesters marched
yesterday demanding action
after a video showing the incident came
out last week
rochester's mayor had asked for calm
after police used tear gas to control
demonstrations on saturday
a grand jury will investigate the case
drika duncan is in rochester forest
where pressure is growing
for the officers to be charged
after a weekend of tense clashes between
protesters and police
waves of peaceful protesters marched to
the rochester public safety building
without
incident sunday night demanding justice
for daniel prude
he died seven days after his arrest in
march
prude is seen here on police body cam
video naked and apparently experiencing
a mental health crisis
the video shows prude being restrained
by officers in the middle of a cold
rochester street
a medical examiner ruled prude's death a
homicide caused by
complications of asphyxia in the setting
of physical restraint
that report also says he was under the
influence of the powerful hallucinogenic
drug
pcp 69 year old shirley thompson is part
of a group of elders organized by the
city
to help broker peace between the
protesters and police
we're trying to appeal to the moral
conscience of our
authority figures in the city marching
alongside some of rochester's oldest
residents were
also some of its youngest three-year-old
tanner marched with his father
tommy walker just wanted to show them
that
people can come together you know
peacefully all races
and he's the future so i want him to get
prepared for the future
protesters want an explanation as to why
it took the city months to reveal the
details of pru's death to the public
rochester's mayor had previously said
she was misled by those in her own
administration
but on sunday she walked back those
comments she maintained she
first saw the body cam video on august
4th
rochester police chief laurent
singletary i provided the mate the mayor
of extra information
uh the morning of the 23rd and uh march
30th as a follow-up when mr fruit passed
away
but if you you told her that a person
od while being arrested did you know
that he was being held down and all the
other stuff
yes overnight police released a
statement
thanking the elder community for helping
out to keep with those protests and keep
them safe now happening off camera that
you can't see right now to my right are
six
naked and partially naked protesters in
the cold street
with spit hoods on drawing of course
more attention
to daniel prude's death michelle wow
that is an image
of course we can't show this morning but
thank you jerica thank you for telling
us about it